literally look what you mean from you
squatting off my face
you're squatting
i thought that's what we were doing
[Music]
buy this from the [ __ ] petrol station
ice cold bro so annoying
give me that room tea work fam worst
type of water
ice cold water is the water it makes me
feel ill
you can't
what's the word i'm looking for you
can't quench your thirst you cook enough
indulge you can't it it sucks the
coldness sucks the moisture out your
mouth it's like salt yeah it's
practically salt it's like drinking salt
water it's horrible ah [ __ ] me i know
exactly what you mean exactly what you
mean you know that room temp i'll slug
the whole thing
i'll drown out oh fam yeah i'll guzzle
it
banging but um
okay
[Music]
all righty um what's good people what's
going on guys um
i hope you're doing well living lavish
feeling good feeling great how are you
hey let's go um you're chilling with
your boys jimmy buckets
fired foreign
[Music]
remember
and guys before we get into the nini
greedy you already know what to do pause
the thing
and then head on actually no yeah head
on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs another
vibe three pounder month tempe a day run
you know the drill um
and get yourself an episode every single
thursday we're talking the most crud
we're running the ix we're running the
picky poisons we're running uh
the gushy gush the film reviews whatever
we're doing over there we live in lavish
so it's uh it's cheaper than chips guys
go and enjoy become part of the family
uh get involved with the zoom calls
get involved with the the am i the
[ __ ] first dibs and uh yeah anyway
have some fun if you're not on there
you're missing you're missing on there
but
if you're just chilling with us today on
youtube snuggle up close to that uh
subscribe button give it a little
clickity clack
um
three fingers of death ring the bell
notifications three no two yeah sorry
two fingers of death oh
have you ever done a three finger
adapting fam you're the the
it goes like that
the pressure of it it sends it it folds
it in
it made me feel weak
because you're trying to fall rather
you're you're trying to straighten your
fingers out
and it ain't happening because the thing
is tight it just folds your fingers in
you come out mangled so yeah it's a two
finger
ring that bell guys get your
notifications every time we drop a vid
um because you already know your boys
are dropping content on the regular now
you know regular dealer um we're getting
into the reaction game so if there's any
reactions you want us to do guys send us
a link um and we'll do that live yeah
mom
and um
as always guys
chirp sitting in the comments
guys girls chap sitting in the comments
um we're obviously like i said we're a
cult we're building a bond
we need breeders yeah yeah we need
hunters we need gatherers and we need
breeders so secure your ting in the
comments
um
and
guys
last but not least
okay without further ado guys
let's get into fire lord fuegs this fun
fact of the day and boogie yogi let's
have some laughs have some fun oh fab
i've never started like that before fam
yes james
i'm not even going to do a fun fact yeah
we'll come back to that all right i've
been holding this in all week all right
let me guzzle this hang on wait wait
i've been holding this in
all week ah shut the [ __ ] up go on all
week okay wait no wait
i don't know i need to prepare for all
week go and it's all thanks to you bro
me i'm gonna say two words go on
midnight mass
mid i wanna night max i wanna rock this
off
fam
series gossip sir let's gossip family
we're a little chatty kathy let's go
the twists
and the turns
in that show
i've never seen anything like it brother
mental alive mental bro
spud thank you for that recommendation
thank you for that recommendation
and obviously i know you said um in the
previous episode i thought if it was a
patreon on youtube as an episode that we
spoke about before
but you said it was the same director
slash writer that did
i already know that shit's on it i
already know that shit's on it bro bang
it midnight
mass didn't make sense do you know how
banging that show is it shouldn't have
been on netflix it should have been a
sky atlantic yeah it should have been a
hbo thing yeah it should have been a hbo
floating madness wow for yeah context
guys for those that don't know about
midnight madness right midnight man is
[ __ ] up midnight mass i'm so mad
talking basketball here midnight mass so
obviously jimmy spoke about a few weeks
ago
it's basically about
this cult that live on an island they're
just
small family i think it's 127 of them
yeah they've got some remote small
islands some fishermen town fishermen
town arsenal nowhere
and [ __ ] is just not sitting right
the the preacher wasn't there the priest
rather the priest goes to the mainland
doesn't come back also we think there's
a [ __ ]
quote-unquote angel on the island that
keeps coming and going coming and going
um
and every character is so relevant as
soon as i saw you know that um that
vigilant church got the woman
as soon as i saw her i was thinking she
is a kind she is a capital c next
tuesday capital but she's so
necessary in that series yeah she's so
necessary in that series
she
you're right
in terms of the fact that they
push the limits and the boundaries of
getting away with stuff
through christianity from if i can't
believe what i watch if you can
interpret it in the bible yeah it's all
if anything goes there fam she walked in
on man with blood on his face and a dead
bernie on the floor she took a deep
breath didn't even look at joe collins
on the floor i stepped over his claw
i was like what are you saying how are
you doing okay what's she's blind she's
blind to everything but god bro
ma maddest thing bro that that show is
unbelievably good you're the only person
that has actually watched it i've tried
to watch it as well family
needs to watch it i've told bear people
to watch it and they're always like oh
what is it and i said like ah
the thing is as well i said like i was
like a horror series and then like i'm
out another listen listen listen it's
it's not scary though it's crazy crazy
it makes you gasp make you like
when i say i watched four episodes in in
the first evening i was like yeah family
sleep that night back to back to bed
when homeboy
um
for in the early episodes donnie who
come back from prison yes when he's
looking outside during the storm yeah
yeah and sees my man out with the with
the hat and the and the thing once
you're period from it where is that just
starting
yeah that's it one senior pre-ordered
anyone seen you prove it nah
i was thinking don't go out there fam do
not chase him and you know i've picked
up a little thing so obviously um in
i think in the first or second episode
he stated that he doesn't go to church
anymore he doesn't want to go to church
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and that that
scene when he was chasing after
monsignor yeah he was saying his name at
first monsignor monsignor then after i
was saying father yeah
he was trying to get him he's trying to
speak to him regardless of the situation
and then you see the cat to the next
episode i'm thinking ra
fan obviously at this point you've not
even seen the angel yet bro you've not
even seen the age of your eyes
the eyes you know when drug dealer
homeboy is looking in that like
abandoned yard yes and just sees the
eyes
i'm not even entering the yard when my
mother said who's there and he heard the
same voice replying back to him saying
who's there that was terrifying by the
way why are you walking into the dunya
why the um
if it was a black populated island
everyone would survive ever because no
one black people don't [ __ ] like that
i'm walking down a scary street in the
middle of the night and there's a door
that goes in an abandoned yard that goes
just creeks and you can't see anything
in it i'm just walking i didn't see it
happen i'm running i'm not walking i'm
sprinting brother regardless of what i'm
carrying there's a lot these lot don't
give a [ __ ] they don't they're too
they're too comfy in their safe little
islands yeah that one two seven that
number they're found oh yeah it's gonna
stay like that bro they're the um the
sheriff goes through it the whole series
sharif sharif
who's got racially infused from the jump
man called him
as soon as he said i was like yeah piss
take from sharif man said it's sheriff
no no sharif sharif did you not think
also
um he reminded you of um
my man from the office he had the look
um
from the office office usa obviously
went in um oh what's his name what's his
name what's his name
the one that went out with pam pam's
husband
who reminded me jim his name jim
jim harper yeah but not
not whilst he was in the office when
he's i think when he was in he's in
something else he does he's got a mini
series on amazon prime oh he's got uh
we'll see his jack reach our subject
creature yeah and he's got like the
beard and everything oh i think i know i
think it's your records i'll have
another look
that didn't mean anything to me i didn't
i don't know why but as soon as i saw
sharif
i saw my man fair play so i feel like i
don't know why but i feel like
they tried to make him look recognizable
yeah yeah but yeah anyway that was that
was a completely that was a complete
segue fam ah do you know what bit
actually
pissed me off in that show i don't know
what you're going to say about
continuing because it was a bit i pissed
me off
the bit that pissed me off was when you
know when they were in the pta meeting
the school meeting yes okay i wasn't
thinking about it all right i didn't
think i was thinking it's very specific
if you're pissed off about this okay um
when my mom was trying to say about like
islam
and then they were like oh like he's
pissed off that they're handing out
bibles to kids and stuff like that and
they [ __ ] [ __ ] woman
she's like yeah obviously i like we're
at school we're trying to educate and
like if kids are interested in religion
then obviously i'm going to give them
the tools to la di da da da da and all
my man had to say was cool like
this is what we believe in islam et
cetera et cetera et cetera we're all
about like
like um
finding out more about knowledge and et
cetera et cetera like that's fine
so if your kids in this school ask me
about islam
like how would you feel about me handing
out the quran everyone's vexed
immediately and they're like okay cool i
see where you're going yeah and she
twangled the whole time
so the whole class was like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah fam i would have
swung everyone in there i hated that
entire scene yeah i wanted to be in
there like shut the [ __ ] up shut the
[ __ ] up
but that was a great scene though oh it
was an amazing it don't it didn't piss
me off like say i wish it didn't happen
it pissed me off because i wanted to be
in there yeah yeah shake everyone like
you men are blind
soul blind but yeah it was don't you
think it was like the coolest
version of like
how religion manipulates so many
hundred percent manipulate not saying it
does it can manipulate anyone into
anything 100
anyone into any 100 bro these religious
fanatics bro not even just that seeing
the whole show oh the whole show the
whole whole show is they they excuse
anything from down to down to religion
bro and it's like if you if you're part
of the church like you're untouchable in
that show yeah yeah yeah yeah you are
untouchable i'd purposely sorry scotty
if i purposely didn't want to mention
anything all week oh
i was binging it i was binging the show
i was like edging i see every episode
it's mad do you agree or disagree with
what i said in terms of
they could have got it done in six
episodes um i still like the last
episode i hated the last episode
i liked the last episode still i think
it was still necessary don't get me
wrong and i understand why they did
seven obviously because of the yeah yeah
yeah
whatever
but
i still think
i think they could have done it in six
not because
like the tail end of the show was longer
i think they could have summarized the
first three episodes quicker oh
because i think the first three episodes
yes wasn't necessary to gather context
but was still a bit long like yeah
yeah
let me just let me forget one second let
me just [ __ ] finish one second one
second because
what [ __ ] second let me finish
because
if you had never
hyped this show up and i just randomly
started watching it i think i would have
lost interest within the first three oh
because it wasn't giving me much but
because i knew how you hyped i already
knew
that this has to be fine let me get over
here only seven episodes i was thinking
yeah okay these men are going to go crud
very very soon i just need to be patient
yeah
and i'm happy i stuck with it all right
very happy i stuck with it um
yeah i reckon
to be fair
get into like the first twist they could
have got that done in two
i don't remember what the first two so
like the big first in terms of like even
the first bit in terms of my man chasing
the thing on the beach yeah yeah um that
could have happened sooner because
that's when [ __ ] really started juicy
because i think that was like tail end
of episode two yeah yeah yeah yeah that
could have been tailored episode one
yeah
and for me is like the good bits
how do i explain it the good bits in
episode seven
could have happened in episode six true
in terms of like
um my girl getting bit and cutting the
things so my man couldn't flee remind me
to come back to that all right cool um
and just in terms of like
that's when they rounded over like this
person's dead this person's dead the
whole thing
i'm thinking because the like the fire
side of it
that already started in episode six and
they just dragged the whole fighting all
the way to the end and the whole thing
locked that singing bit off
at the end for me
oh yeah i was thinking what's going on
yeah
but
because i feel like the reason why
they did that
was because you know they sang in
episode six as well
when they were walking through the town
once they switch off all the electricity
yeah i feel like it was one of those
ones where they sang before they thought
they were going to be saved and they
sang off the wedding yeah i'm going to
die i get it man i think i get it i i do
get it i just all i remember thinking
was just like this the episode's done
once once she did the kaka i thought
it's done now because once we once
they'd all established
are we [ __ ] like once the the rec
center was done
they all knew his game set over now so
but there was still like another half an
hour of the episode left after that
point
and i was like
i already knew before i knew what was
happening next i already knew from that
point the thing's done i don't need to
watch another half an hour of this um
but yeah fam oh yeah go back to the so i
was
obviously we saw this thing fly away
and that was probably there was probably
still about what 10 minutes left or
whatever
i was a bit annoyed that they could have
taken it that next step further to
actually either one a show the angel
either combust in to
trying to like find its feet while it's
flying probably land somewhere yeah and
then it gives like an intuition of maybe
a season two something you know yeah
only all we saw was it fly away and that
was it yeah it would have been nice if
it like
crash-landed on a boat or something
that's what i'm thinking we don't know
we don't know whether it's done or not
yet because i was thinking that we're
going to end it show the credits and
then go back to that scene see him
flying in crash land somewhere i was
expecting that yeah yeah because if that
had happened and be like okay season two
may pop
season two may pop up we don't know if
there's going to be cc yes
you man midnight mass middle east
and the next day is oh bro i'm closing
my eyes now when obviously the twist of
um
one month my um pruitt was always
shaking and stuff and then obviously
when the angel came a man just gave him
the thing that i needed
and then my man came in it was like it
came into the rec center whilst that was
happening
i came into the wrestling my breath i'm
holding because i was thinking there's
no way they can just dump you off lead
characters like that no yeah yeah yeah
leader and i was thinking the thing
launched at him
launched at him
launched at him why died monsignor just
looked at him down and i said fam
when homie put homeboy on the spot and
said you see when i was getting gripped
did you lick the tank did you look man i
said
yeah yeah if we're being open or nice if
we're being open honestly i did i would
have rocked him in his face just then
you're scum fam when he knocked on his
girl's door he spies his door
and he was the one that was there i was
thinking what's going on yes same same
thing what's going on firm same same i
was thinking nah
now i found when she was like so you've
dragged me out here there's nobody i was
thinking he's not he's not gonna do it i
know he's thirsty
he's not he's not gonna do it he's not
fam did the whole team twist and turns
everywhere every episode there was a
twist and turn there was there actually
was [ __ ] it was such a such a good
series
the bit that pissed me off because you
were talking about the
pa pta meeting in the classroom the bit
that pissed me off was um
when i need to remember her name because
i keep saying this yet you know who i'm
talking about but she's it was the
annoying lady oh right yeah yeah casting
characters her name is
bev is it bev keegan bevky oh
yeah so when bev keen um
went to they were waiting for pruitt to
come to come to mass during this was
still during the day yes
the joe collins situation yeah
and then she went back to mass it was
like everything's fine forever and it
was like you and you come with me
and then obviously these men were
shocked but
when they first stepped into the room it
looked as if these men already knew
waguan i know what you mean you know but
then when she was like yeah do this do
this do this take this man to the body
blah blah blah and then drop him
they were like they were questioning
everything fam and she was like how dare
you question god something something
something this man was the man that
[ __ ] [ __ ] up your daughter this
that any other blah blah blah screaming
at his [ __ ] face here
he's he's the man you know
i would never hit a woman but if that
was you say screaming at me like that
i'll put my leg behind your leg place my
palm on your face and slam your head to
the ground
slam your head to the ground bro i would
have dropped her fam
it's a murder scene this is my town
i'm the mayor of this town this is a
murder scene i don't care what you say
beth i don't care what you're saying i
don't care what you you're talking
gibberish and you're all going down
you're all going down oh
bro
you might need to watch your show fam
midnight mass off the hook it may have
seemed as if we spoiled a lot but trust
me we haven't trust me
and i'm seething i want to go on
my gums are itching i want to get it all
out oh yeah oh man you won't spot a few
hands so good oh my goodness what a show
what is great
thank you so much for that
recommendation that's probably one of
the best recommendations you and me yeah
fam 100
when i watched it after the first
episode i was like oh i'm in
i'm in shed some love over to our
friends at manscaped so you already know
it's the gifting season mmm very true
you giving you get very true so
ladies if you want that gush gush in the
bed
where that wet wet that long strong that
smooth criminal
get your boy the performance package 4.0
it comes with all the luxury details you
already know what it is luxury details
led light on the thing guess all the
nooks and crannies anti-nick technology
bro waterproof waterproof my g
one what else are we looking for
on the other side guys i already know
what it's like on this time of the year
they don't know what they want you ask
what you want for christmas they're like
oh you know what i like la la la la land
bro
she's gonna think you're crazy but get
at the performance package as well you
want to axe axe that razor burn she
don't want that in it these guys are
tired of getting waxed and they're tired
of shaving all the time they hate that
razor burn
they don't know about man's escape it
works it's gender neutral it works both
ways
yeah it's gender neutral blood sword so
um guys get the gift that keeps on
giving the code is sng sierra november
golf sierra november golf 20 off free
shipping worldwide you already know what
it is hopping over there manscape.com
and um
you know
enjoy christmas
[Laughter]
oh
hi guys
you just caught me here
thirsting for knowledge
while you're here
let's talk about
black friday
s g merch
light
comforting you may be wondering it looks
great but
what can i actually use it for
but the real question is
what can't you do whether it's
chilling with the homies
that
saturday sneaky link
[Music]
or even if it's for some
extracurricular
solo
activities
[Music]
guys the point is is black friday is
just around the corner and shits and
gigs are giving you 30
off
starting from friday
26 november ending tuesday 30th november
links in the description
get your [ __ ] feel lavish
and do what it do
until next time
did you know we've spoiled it any
further did you know it was my man the
whole time
no up until
um
i don't know when i realized but i
obviously didn't realize the whole time
i i thought
the only thing i thought was
bev knew the whole time oh okay but
obviously she didn't she didn't yeah
when you watch it more of context why
she didn't but i thought she was in the
whole thing the whole time yeah but no i
didn't know he was in the whole time
what about yourself um i love the whole
time i did though once
you know when my man said like oh
i've been told it's just uh like it's
just probably gonna be for day mass it's
probably just gonna be me and you to the
u
uh in the wheelchair when he first oh
yes because
the first day he showed face he was like
oh monsieurs told me about you he was
reading a lot of facts about this person
reading a lot of facts about that how do
you remember all these things yeah but i
didn't question it i just let the thing
run you know yeah
and then when this thing slides about
and then the picture on the wall in his
office i was thinking
oh big man is you yeah yeah that's you
fam yeah
live issue live a show way better than
haunting a hill house and things i
enjoyed hill house so did the man was
all right as well i've not seen that but
i wanted hill house was really good for
me at the time i was watching [ __ ]
this is a shock
show this is a show yeah yeah
show show um but yeah the the the
midnight messes he's the writers are
what they've upped their game they have
they have bro i think he wrote it and
directed it is it and he's i was
checking you know what i'm like when i
watch that you do you love it i do some
research he's married all
he's with the i think her name is kate
siegel the pregnant lady i'll swear
they're together she was in the in um
she's in both she's on both of them and
she was in i think it's hush as well he
directed that oh is it yeah oh so they
work a lot together um and uh because
they've got the
the pops
he's in hill house as well and blind
manner i think
the
um the guy who went to prison his dad
he's pops oh is it yeah yeah yeah he's
the dad in hill house okay okay and uh
sharif he's in batman yeah i read that
but i didn't i've not seen blimey he's
british i'm sure oh is it well he's
british in blind man
guys so for context right he's an actual
sheriff in the show his name is not
sharif i can't cameron what his name is
but because he's
muslim he's the only muslim in this
christian island of 127 people joe
collin is the town drunk just calls him
sharif it's painful painfully wrong
fam is painful bro
but he's the sheriff of the saudis his
name is sharif
but yeah [ __ ] when
his son said he wanted to go to mass and
when his son drank the ting i've never
wanted to be in sharif shoes in my
entire life he was screaming
my son thumb they grips them back i'm
arresting everyone
i'm resting i don't know how i'm
arrested i'm shooting family when they
were about to leave the mass and then
the angel was standing there mine came
in like this
i would have had i would have collapsed
100 i would have collapsed when i say
twists and turns you just don't expect
to see anything nah fam i'm not doing it
oh what a show yeah it's it's live it's
a live show guys watch the show
it's a live show
it's i'm so glad you you watch it
enjoyed it i haven't seen spotlight yet
though
but i'm going to after midnight mass i
watched
dark waters
moving
good dark waters is a smoothie it's a
movie it's a movie mark ruffalo doesn't
give up
he does relentless give up movie
relentless oh thank you for those
recommendations brother yeah i had a
good week in that aspect yeah it sounds
like it i had a terrible week in general
oh
oh
i'm fam
exhausting i swear just work work work
well obviously monday i was here tuesday
i had to do like daily life stuff and
boy just catching up on everything i got
a trim i went out for some food i had a
work meet and i had this or that and the
other so wednesday was literally my only
day to myself so i was off monday
tuesday wednesday off on monday about we
were recording on monday
so wednesday was my only day to myself
just doing [ __ ] all yeah yeah chilling
relaxing i didn't even go to the gym
that's how much really i just wanted to
be less i just wanted to be left alive
yeah yeah yeah in my own bubble
thursday trained went straight to work
afterwards 4 12.
um
friday
didn't train 2 12 that was my shift
saturday didn't train 111 yesterday
didn't train 11 11.
i'm here all day today i'm working 11 10
tomorrow 11 10 wednesday
um
2 12 thursday
6 close friday
and i think of 4 12 saturday so i think
thursday night will be the only time
i've said a lot i've set an alarm every
day since wednesday night and i will
until nah bro i'm i'm i'm on the brink
bro
i'm gonna bring up losing it
guys
patreon.com let's get out i'm on the
brink of losing let's get flakes out
please please please please please
please out there because it's suffering
now next week is the five days a week
now yeah yeah yeah yeah
my extra day is gone for christmas for
five weeks nah nah that fucking's a long
time it's a long time yeah
guys patreon.com
bro oh i feel it for you
that's what i say like when i said about
the thursday thing couldn't do it bro i
can imagine what i couldn't physically
couldn't face it
i literally couldn't face it anymore
[ __ ] jesus christ
regurgitated the family
sometimes
yeah this whole work thing
is it's a scam it's all a scam it's all
it's enough to feel like that my g you
really shouldn't on my feet bro my back
my lower back i'm fam i'm getting a
twinge here on my on the top of my spine
close to my neck where it's
i feel like
if someone just pushed my neck one more
it's gonna crack
it's gonna [ __ ] crack and i'm gonna
drop to my knees
it happens
it's happened twice now happened
yesterday and the night before
i'm on the verge bro when i say
i've got a bulging disc down here fam
listen it's getting worse and worse by
the day yeah i'm terri i'm doing the
most now i'm doing exercises i'm doing
like yoga poses if i'm like you know the
laying cobra this thing and the child
i'm doing it constantly my pelvis is
just arching constantly all throughout
the day fam i've been doing all sorts of
these teeth
glute bridges i've been squeezing my
cheeks will crack nuts right now i've
been squeezing through that just to
relieve anything i've been hanging to
like decompress my spine i've been
hanging on
i do that all right i've just been
hanging from
have you ever hugged and then pushed
your neck forward uh
cracks down here it feels great i've
been hanging so when i hang
the the the disc that that's located in
the bowl fam you can literally i can
feel my heartbeat in it it wants to
crack
the pain is unbearable and i'm just
hanging
i'm just hanging for dear life just like
when is this going to end yeah oh i went
to um i went ice skating
yesterday i haven't been in ice skating
ages neither do i first of all
for anyone who thought it's like riding
a bike it's not it's not because when we
used to go yeah years ago your boy was
doing a crossover step yeah we were like
i was moving around
i thought yeah let me run some some
quick skates yeah jumped on i wasn't
even there for long i was just jumped on
fam as soon as i touched the ice i was
scattering
it took me like 15 minutes to get my
swing back i still never got the the
step over thing i would have been there
for an hour
but anyway fam after like
i'm talking like three or four just
leaning forward here
my back was in bits bro and i'm thinking
what am i gonna do yeah literally what
am i gonna at this point what am i gonna
do if your boy can't even do this
without pain then what what what have i
got left i said it a few episodes ago
bro i'm gonna be in a wheelchair before
40.
and it's not okay something needs to
give fam my leg day you should see well
you obviously saw my leg of the week my
leg days are limited
i can't do anything i can't load the
spine yeah i just can't yeah yeah i i
don't squat anymore bro i had to do so
i did front squats the other day
for like 60 kilos for like reps but i
had to my back has to be like this my
jeep it can't go like that my back has
to be like this straight as an arrow
yeah so i'm doing front squats because i
can't do back squats front squats i had
to do
heel elevated
so literally my ass is just going in a
straight line yeah yeah and i'm using
everything i have to keep my elbows from
dipping anywhere forward because if i
crouch
you won't see your boy for a few weeks
we'll be doing zoom calls from my bed
it's it's on the edge i don't know what
to do i'm gonna have to see some kind of
consultant yeah i need to see so i
haven't got the time i need to see
someone i haven't got the time i need to
see someone did you buy the cream i
suggested like the anti-inflammatory
thing nah i told you i'm too g for that
friend you need bro you need to
even even though
i still get pain towards the tail end of
the day i use it in the morning i use it
at night yeah yeah carries me for a good
eight nine hours stay low so less
trust me
you need some form of remedy especially
especially using it before you go to bed
because obviously that's when your body
rests yeah yeah recuperates and we get
whatever the word is i'm looking for but
yeah you need to get inside all right i
think the reason i don't get it is
because like
how do i explain it
i can live with the pain
even when it gets worse i can live with
the pain it's the fact that i know the
pain means something
that bothers me okay does that make
sense okay like i can live with like
like sitting here is painful for me
right now doing everything it hurts like
i can deal with it it doesn't actually
it doesn't it's not the pain
the pain isn't like a 10 out of 10. it's
literally like a mild 3 4 out of ten
but it's because i know the pain is due
to something like something is seriously
wrong there to cause pain with
everything i do that's the issue it's
not that the pain is so bad like bad
that i need to get rid of the pain i
don't know what he means
all the time that i'm like
big man am i dying yeah yeah literally
am i dying like what's going on and the
fact that it gets worse it's just like
okay this is bad now like this is really
really bad uh so i'm gonna have to see
like i said i haven't got the time and
i've got the energy i'm just going to
keep doing my my yogurt
and then just do more and more of it and
hopefully it helps but femme doesn't
seem to be
but um anyway
i've got trash news oh hit me
fam do you know who there's a band
called um
like brass against have you ever heard
of it brass against they're like a weird
like combination of people it's like a
weird band but um there's a there's a
uh their lead singers are yet called uh
they're like a kind of like rockish like
metalish band right okay they're um
they're lead things sophia
what's it called aristo or something
like i've got on my phone um fam they
did a concert the other week
my girl pissed on someone
she
this is so interesting to me this is so
interesting to me right so let me find
this thing
so
it's got a video to it and everything
you pissed on she calls someone on stage
and pissed on his face
what you can see the video everything
and she pisses hard
it's not we're not talking a drizzle
ting
she fully fires out squats on man's face
and pisses all over him whoa i'll show
you so um let me see brass against
singer sophia arista horrified fans when
she urinated on a man's face during a
performance in daytona
the lead singer uh from the band was in
the middle of a set uh during the
welcome to rockville concert on thursday
night when she announced to the crowd
that she needed the bathroom and
couldn't wait any longer
but instead of leaving stage sofia
dragged up a male fan from the audience
got him to lie down on the stage and
relieved herself all over him fam here's
the video
let me start it again bro
bro
how's it go
it's good
she pisses hard on him found
yeah g
man's da man's loving it as well
no
[Music]
it's coming out like um like you know
when you twist the head on the shower on
a shower thing and it's
changing
it changes the pressure it gushes out
that's what it's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah no brother it came out out
imagine still like ah
but to be fair right listen listen
listen listen listen linda um
linda listen listen
bro
when i watched it
and she's paying as well
when i watched it
i think i finally understood the appeal
of why someone would want to get pissed
on
not that i would want to be that guy
but the way she kind of like sexually
like did the little wiggle dancing and
she's like
homeboy i want to piss on your face like
the difference between just like a
random girl saying i want to piss on
someone and saying that someone like
he's paid money to go and see this girl
perform like
you can understand this he's in awe of
her yeah yeah
and he's like he looks like he's in his
50s 60s just some fat rocker guy
like never in a million years with this
absolutely
banging goddess dragged my man on stage
he saw puss fan he saw puff here yeah
yeah
at that point he was down for any and
everything anything
so bro i could in that moment i i
literally was the first time in my
entire life i was like
ah i can see
i can see the like
i can see the kink i can see the appeal
because if
especially in that environment as well
because there's a there in that
in that um
like i think how to explain it so you
know like dominatrix vibes right yeah
when guys
like obviously will get a dominatrix and
they do that
there's
a clear hierarchy in that situation
but
there's a hierarchy of power in that
situation
but i feel like a lot of the reason i'm
i'm not into being dominated anyway
i'm just not into it anyway yeah
i need to be the dominant one yeah yeah
yeah um so
there's no appeal for me there but if i
was into it i still feel like i would
struggle because
we don't when she
say if we got a hotel room
when she comes to the door
there's no hierarchy of power here
like we're equal we're even and we need
to find a way to create a hierarchy and
where you're here and i'm here
and
getting us there is just awkwardness to
me yeah yeah he just feels
like yeah yeah it just feels awkward
yeah
but in that situation where he's a part
of a crowd of thousands of people and
she is the main attraction in this whole
arena
there is already a set hierarchy of
power she is here and i am here
so i'm already acceptant of that before
she says you come on come on stage and
lie the [ __ ] down
then i can see where he's like
he would giggle
he'd say do what you want and when she
yanked her ting down and squatted over
man's face and he's just seeing a pawn
of this banging
thing that is running this whole show
yeah it makes sense fam and she said
shut the [ __ ] up and take this i pissed
on his face i can see why man was like
he relished in it if i'm grinding he
didn't open his mouth which is probably
for the best he must have been a married
man
but he might say ah
i could literally think i can see why
that would turn it on
because
yeah literally from the power complex
there's no way he's dominating that
situation regardless of what he's into
in his own sexual life there's no way
he's it's impossible it's impossible
she's up here and you're down here
there's no matter what yeah so this
thing tells you and you're a fan fan of
hers yeah and you as far as you're
concerned you're invisible to her you
don't exist she's everything you don't
exist she said she literally doesn't
know who you are you know everything
about she says i need a piss lie down
man's heart would have been racing
yeah what do you mean it just lie down
yeah yeah yeah
fam
yeah i could see i watched it i thought
oh
that's when you explain like that
obviously i clocked it from when i
watched the video but when you explain
it in detail like that it makes sense
yeah power play makes sense fam i could
see it i could see it
and probably if i was him i'd probably
let her piss on me too
but it's only afterwards you'd be like
what the [ __ ] when i have to get up and
go back down to work
you see this circle [ __ ] engulf around
you
you're gonna spend the rest of the show
just by yourself staring like
i've got piss on it i stink a piss
you have to leave the show you have to
leave the show
and even imagine if you ride there with
your misses
what are you supposed to say when you
get back yeah i i don't even know i
don't even know
raw but yeah interesting but she had to
she had to send out an apology and
everything oh is it yeah so i got
carried away i would have been like do
your team firm
you ain't gonna say [ __ ] to me i loved
it
it was all part of the show i was here
yeah i was here for a dewey one it's
your show oh my goodness oh yeah i'm a
humble spectator do your thing man but
she pissed on him hard
famic hit the water pressure
yeah it fizzed out
it fizzed out
i couldn't believe what i was watching
james
wow
but yeah yeah it was fully mad um
i've actually got the fun fact now okay
so we
we go back to that now it's about will
smith oh okay sonny you like this one
i'm gonna read a quote that you said and
i'm gonna read
the fact about him as well
i'm will smith
no one would ever believe i killed my
father on purpose
i'm one of the best actors in the world
my my 9-1-1 call would be academy award
level
ally
so
the hollywood star has opened up about
because obviously he's got a new book
he's got a book it's a tell-all thing in
it yeah yeah it's a memoir
yeah yeah
so the hollywood stars opened up about
his childhood in his new memoir called
will revealing that his revealing that
despite his father being very very
present in his life he was an abusive
alcoholic who beat his mother
years later when will smith senior was
battling with cancer the 50 year 53 year
old actor says he contemplated ending
his father's life
he explains one night i was dedicated
delicately
i can't get my words out one night as i
delicately wheeled him from his bedroom
towards the bathroom a darkness arose
within me
as a child i'd always tell myself that i
would one day avenge my mother
that when i was big enough when i was
strong enough and when no and when i was
no one no longer a coward i would slay
him
smith said there was decades of pain and
anger and resentment
blah blah blah i'm gonna read after
comments he said other quotes he said
rather
he said i shook my head and proceeded
the wheelchair
sorry
are you good bro i am
you good bro
the
the quote i was about to read
was already explained in the second
paragraph so that's why the quote didn't
really mean yeah yeah because obviously
he said he wheeled his um
dad from the bedroom to the bathroom and
he said the quote was he wanted to
he was at the top of the edge of the
stairs and he wasn't just [ __ ]
flinging he wanted the [ __ ] flinging
but he just carried on going to the
bathroom oh cool so that's what i was
going to say
it's um so he didn't kill his dad he
didn't he did it
i was waiting i was waiting
um because i was thinking are you sure
you want to put this in your book family
or go to prison yeah he said i paused at
the top of the stairs i could have
shoved him down and easily gotten away
with it hmm i've heard there's a lot of
stuff on in this book that he talks
about like
um jaden wanting to like emancipate
himself and stuff from the family and
all these things and talking about like
how he had like mad guilt like bringing
him into one of the movies that did [ __ ]
uh
bringing her in or him her bringing him
in jayden jay dunder you don't i think
he's in jail sorry jaden yeah when he
jaden was in uh what movie was in
the one where i haven't seen it they're
in the jungle in some alien planet or
some [ __ ] uh yeah i've seen it it's
called what them two yeah just them two
yeah it's called
i'm sorry in the cinema
[ __ ] horrendous movie yeah yeah um
keep talking but yeah he put him in that
movie and it did [ __ ] and he had all
this guilt about it and all this stuff
and um
yeah so he he like something along the
lines of jaden wanted to like emancipate
himself when he was 18 and like separate
himself from the family oh wow and he
talks about him and jada and their sex
life and tingling there i think as well
after earth after earth that's the one
movie yeah yeah and then um
he talks about how i think he talks
about it like in terms of him just don't
bang at all
i think they only bang other people
oh wow i'm not sure i need to read this
i'm not going to read the book someone
needs to write a clip and read the book
i'm not reading that i'm not reading the
book yeah um but i'm pretty sure they're
satin along the lines of like i heard a
lot of people saying like oh all this
drama about like jada's trash and all
this stuff and how she's like aired out
all their [ __ ] and all this stuff and
then the book comes out it's like oh
apparently they just don't [ __ ] each
other at all like the only bang other
people i think
oh wow something like that that's um i
don't know how to register that
information
that's a bit weird
i think it is but also i i
i think it is but i think is also not
like you have to
i mean to not bang her at all well i
don't know if they've i don't think it's
a case of they have an agreement like do
not [ __ ] me but i think it's a case of
like
probably a case of bro they've been
together for years and years and years
bro in terms of like
they can both get as much pom slash pipe
as they want
so
i think that i think in my i say i think
i'm i'm clutching at straws here but i
have no idea what their mindset is but i
would say like it wouldn't be weird to
me if you hear that like bro like
we love each other we've been together
for years but it's like
we just don't [ __ ] in comparison to what
gets thrown at us in our dm's on a daily
basis like we don't find each other
attractive like that
like jada's in her 50s she's looking to
get banged by a 29 year old
i'm in my 50s i'm looking to slay 25
year old [ __ ] as well just like
sexually we don't we're not compatible
anymore like we're old people and we
were trying to live young and live
lavish like we're not gonna get that by
banging each other and maybe they do
from now on again maybe they don't i
don't know but when you're i guess
if you can get to that level of honesty
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if a lot of
people who have been together for the la
for that
a long time
like this they get yeah they get they
get into they're into different things
as well that makes sense and it's like
we don't want to break up like we love
each other this is my best friend this
is my partner that's my mother and my
kids and stuff like that why on earth we
would break up like we could just bang
other people all the time it's easy
it's
you have no idea how easy it is
you have no clue i said he could have
killed his pops and got away with it
must be
for will smith who's making bank who he
wants when he wants what he wants that
he hasn't got to worry about odenting
there
he hasn't got worry about all that and
his hosts stay quiet clearly clearly
because there's not been a whisper oh no
i've not heard anyone come out the
woodworks the most i've ever heard was a
potential thing with him and margot
robbie when they did that that robin
movie
but apart from i should look back in
that movie
there's a few she's got a weird thing
that how she is clearly extremely
banging but in certain movies
wolf of wall street disgusted and that
uh what is that movie called
right is it called bright no it's
definitely no that's another movie smith
movie it's called um
focus focus yeah yeah i knew it was one
one stupid word
one stupid adjective that doesn't make
sense i knew it was that bright focus
whatever
um
yeah she's banging wolf of wall street
and focus she is
unbearably banging yeah she's disgusting
disgusted bearably banging
yeah it doesn't make sense how banging
she is sometimes fam she was the perfect
cast in for wolverwall street in terms
of when my man said
to him her pawn was like cocaine like he
physically couldn't get enough yeah fam
when you see her in that movie you're
like oh of course bro of course i get it
i understand she looks like she tastes
like aquafina like she looks like she
tastes like
vos ph 7. the balance is just nil it's
just neutral neutral yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that makes sense yeah [ __ ] it out
yeah you know wow yeah oh oh
yeah bro she
in that
if she
was
performing if she was a singer if
margaret robbie and wolfer wall street
happen to be a singer and say get the
[ __ ] on stage and i've got a piss
do what you want
let's see if he's handsome fran
do what needs to be done
i'll deal with the questions
i am a pawn in this game of chess use me
use me fam
sacrifice me do what needs to be done
you can't squat those cheeks over my
face do what you after that do at least
do what you need to do
do what you need i won't complain i'm
not gonna lie to you there would have to
be security around because she couldn't
squat on my
above me yeah without me dragging her
towards my lips
there is no way in high heaven
that she's squatting over i'm laying on
flat on the ground yeah yeah and she's
squatting pump out baby out
i'm draping her by her kneecaps
come here
to my lips i'm drenching up my kneecaps
i have to
there has to be security around
there has to be security around
[Laughter]
margaret robbie yeah that thing
to be fair
that michael sofia squatting on my man's
face could have gone west
he could have been like tom tom
he's a big guy as well could have
started and just started boxing
what's security gonna do they haven't
got enough time for them the deed is
done she's been eating
she's been eating on stage
they have to refund everything oh
they'll have to lock up the whole show
and the thing is she wouldn't have a leg
to stand on you literally look what you
mean from you squatting off my face
you're squatting on my side i thought
that's what we were doing
you can't show me bear puss and expect
me not to lick it
it's here fam i'm looking at it like
this like this you can smell everything
i can smell it you know when it's warm
it doesn't matter anything but it just
smell the aura yeah it's body heat here
i'm gripping you cuz you know
i'm not letting go
the security will drag me by my legs
drapes me off stage
drapes me off aids
there's no way i'm letting go yeah it is
it could never be margot robbie
i said i'm dragging it to my lips
i don't know why that's so funny
my cheeks are hurting oh fam dragonair
bro i'm with you jesus jesus
you can't give me those kind of
opportunities
[Music]
that's funny that was funny jesus i
can't breathe let me drink some water
oh you got them toxic
i was literally
literally just about to say
let's do
some toxic traits okay
so um last week on igrc man what are
your ex's or your partner's toxic traits
you man came clutch you deliver the
goods
we need to hear these so here we go yeah
yeah yeah
so
first one pathological liar and cheat
that's a standard it's just a no-brainer
yeah
that's that's not even a trick that's a
personality personality
personality disorder
um he checked my outfits before i wore
them or bought them he what checked my
outfits before i wore them or bought
them i was to give him the green light
or no the red oh yeah yeah that's too
much man stop he only spoke to me on
weekdays
my love
me and more you're a sighting
he does church on weekdays he goes out
on a weekend he only spoke to me on
weekdays he's with his family on the
weekend he's real family fam yeah he's
turning uh his phone's off huh well the
phone he uses for you is off logged out
of instagram everything too phonetic oh
he only spoke to me on weekdays that's
hilarious to me oh yeah you're an
ultimate sighting
ultimate
yeah yeah he works in the city in the
week and he's home in the suburbs on the
weekends yeah
oh that's hilarious oh oh she ate on the
toilet
that's vulgar fam that's vulgar that's a
toxic trait that's a red flag that's an
ick
get out
we're not together anymore get out
she ate on the toilet
eight what
literally in one another was there food
already in there or did she bring the
plate in
i need answers to everything i don't
have the specifics
nasty yeah that's great as soon as i
read that i was like yuck no [ __ ]
wonder yeah yeah yeah
for some reason i don't know why but
this one reminded me of toby you're
going
my ex used the you know the three monkey
emojis the this one the this one and
this one i don't know why but it just
it just reminded me i don't know if toby
uses those emojis wow but for some
reason
i'm sure toby does that i don't know why
you just called toby yeah on everyone's
internet
you just sold your boys into yeah you
just violated your friend on everyone's
internet
but yeah my ex used those monkey emojis
understandable yeah yeah no man used
those emojis
wow faked being pregnant to stop me from
leaving her oh my god fam
i ah you know what yeah i wish that was
a surprise to hear
john i mean i wish that was a surprise
to hear
yeah i'll just do that you know i've
seen it bro
i've seen it
i've seen it with my own eyes i've seen
someone do that
it's crazy bro and then they just like
and then they lie about it not going
through
and then
we're supposed to be this again nah
and then they'll pretend like they're
suffering emotionally
because they lost the
thing that's the devil right there
yes that's the devil right there yes it
is wow yeah continue fam that's the most
toxic of all of them you can't top that
surely
you're ready to top it i don't know
loads of fair play i probably can but i
don't know yet
um when they say it's okay to confide in
them and then they use that thing as
ammo in an argument
i'm surprised i didn't write that
that's every x i've ever had
that's every x i've ever had
that's it
man raised the roof you know
big mountain that's every x i've ever
had that's not hilarious that's
hilarious don't bait me into sharing my
innermost feelings and then flip it on
me in an argument bro oh we'd have to
fight them once bro you'd have to fight
fam yeah that one's just like yeah i
grew up without a dad it was tough it's
two months unlike that's why your dad
left you cuz
you fathered this [ __ ]
that's why no one will ever love you wow
even your dad didn't love you fam yeah
that's every x i've ever had bro
yeah i wow i'm happy someone wrote that
there's a lot in it but that needed to
be said i'm happy someone wrote that
yeah yeah oh
fun
oh god go on go on go on
this reminds me of one of your stories
jesus
stealing my money to spend on bus fares
and meal deals
you know exactly the story i'm talking
about to be fair the time i stole that p
it wasn't it was a one-off thing but
i've never done it since i've never done
it before and that wasn't for meal deals
bro that was for survival
but yeah that was
that was me in my most toxic state
true that's the most toxic version of
james that's ever existed oh my god
but yeah i thieved it and lied about it
by any chance you see my um the last
five my last five i need nah babes nah
nah nah
i ain't seen it since i paid the cabbie
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] hell
all right
saying i'll kill myself every time i try
and break up with us bro
that's toxic that's this is fam
that's toxicity bro yeah that's cancer
right there wow yeah [ __ ] her
fam
oh god what god
banging a man behind my back
dot dot dot
he told me he was straight
oh wow i don't even know how to unpack
that if i was the if i was the yeah i
wouldn't know how to unpack that
he's been banging a bread and the
the thing off he told me he was straight
like say if you'd been open with me
this could have happened of course it
wouldn't have he's a liar anyway but
still
ah
yeah those closet gays
that's toxic still
wow
yeah yeah
my location always had to be on um
that's possessive lock him off i already
know it's a guy lock him off he was a
guy
[Laughter]
i already know i can i know what traits
guys and girls have
they're so black and white
[Laughter]
um leaving her belongings behind by
accident by accident
so she'd have an excuse to come back and
get them yeah
again yeah get out of here man
he used to physically fight with his dad
i couldn't even i could have stepped my
pops like that yeah bro
physically fight with his dad nah
don't you think it's mad that i'm big
fertile yeah i'm still convinced my dad
will knock me out i know my dad would
love me they're psychological that no
matter what
you just think your dad will knock you
out it right we're 30 right my dad is
maybe 63.
for some reason he's
he just looks like he's still getting
bigger it just doesn't make sense his
hands and his feet are so massive
it just doesn't make sense like
i know if he would slap me today yeah it
would feel like i'm a child again yeah
yeah
i'm four or five years old again you
would you'll beat the shot yeah yeah
yeah the [ __ ] shot at me but yeah we
had a i was at my dad's a few months ago
yeah and my little sister my little
sister's obsessed with arm wrestles
that's cute and she was like oh james
like you and dad should arm wrestle and
as one of them was just like i don't
think we should
but you don't have to tell her that yeah
i was like
that'll meet me because it's like
i don't want to do that to either of us
because if i win
i'll grow six inches on the spot
the tide have it just shifted
yeah and if he wins it's like what am i
yeah because if he if he banged it i was
like bat couldn't he looked it looked at
me i'd be thinking
what was all this gym for man what have
i been doing for 10 years in his 50s
what's going on bro it makes no sense
yeah so we couldn't we couldn't we
couldn't it's best for everyone if you
never viewing your grown man don't ever
arm wrestle your dad oh my goodness it
breaks the whole thing yeah he won't
invite me around ever again if i win no
it's not
this
i don't understand he's just begging for
fights
i'd go into the kitchen after she'd
bought the kettle and empty it and make
her wait again
she bought the kettle and he'd empty the
kettle
and then leave it there so she has to
fill it up and boil it again
i'll dump you the first time you do that
man's releasing his own toxicity
i don't understand why you'd even admit
that so that's he talked about himself
he's talking about himself
[ __ ] that guy man
that's a [ __ ] thing to do
bro
he's uncalled for
it's just uncalled for
you know there's no other way to put it
yeah fam
that's just like
you're that's the thing that you find
hilarious that you know she [ __ ]
hates but you don't give a [ __ ] don't
give a flight just love [ __ ] with her
yeah just yeah [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that
guy oh this is a good one never
admitting when they're wrong and a guy
wrote that about a girl all right cool
yeah of course that's fine that's
important that's very important yeah
very important
uh telling me to shush before he picks
up the phone to his mum that's not his
mum big man
that's not his mom he's written mum
there that's not his mum he's not his
mum still that's not his mom yeah yeah
also also actually actually this is
actually like a subconscious
um
like uh red flag slash like toxic trait
if i have to tell you to shush when my
phone's ringing you're toxic um
if i have to if i feel the need to have
to tell you to be quiet when someone's
calling me then you're toxic as in you
as the person or the the girl was
talking the girls toxic okay the girl's
toxic because i should you should
already know
doesn't matter who's calling me yeah
yeah yeah i don't want to hear words at
your mouth i'm on the phone yeah so if
you're intentionally going to be loud so
you know
so whoever needs to know is on the phone
that you're there yeah yeah you're toxic
100
i hear you i hear that i hear that
this one wrote not a trait
but he locked me in the bathroom so i
don't me i didn't meet his family when
they were over
that's that's psychotic that is
captivity
yeah that's oppression what are you
doing
that's how could they be together after
that i don't understand so i don't know
how people get themselves in certain
situations bro i don't know how people
get themselves in these situations and
then once it's happened
how they're just not like
yeah bye though yeah we need to address
what's happened and then i'm dipping
yeah of course like you need to explain
to me what the [ __ ] is going on your
head and then after you do i'm leaving
bro i have to leave i have to leave yeah
yeah
all right this one is jokes
farts under the bed covers then flaps
the cover so me and my baby can smell it
not even our baby
me and my baby can smell it
that's that's
that's too disrespectful bro that's too
disrespectful very
very disrespectful brother
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah wow cool
uh that's enough all right that's enough
for now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was hilarious oh fam yeah yeah
that's
okay
[Laughter]
we're gonna leave that one there and
then we'll we'll we'll pull some more up
next time yeah um but yeah i've got an
am i the [ __ ] actually okay okay
cool so man said am i the [ __ ]
uh this happened a while ago pre-covered
um
and i'd gone out for a night out with
the lads it was a friday night hit the
hot spot got the vip and the
excuse me and the drinks are flowing
girls come in and out and there's about
eight men so we invited some potentials
to come vibe with us uh in the section
we were in and then one of the guys
invited a few more girls next thing we
know the ratio is mad like two for each
guy
i start talking to this redhead we chat
we dance
i'm doing the most
and at the end of the night i've stuck
it on her
and said are you coming to mine
or not she comes back we do the business
um
man said i'm drunk drunk i'm not gonna
lie so i'm really focused on trying to
give her a good night
she spends the night mainly because i
pass out after the smash
thanks
um
wake up and we talk for a while i find
out she's the sister of one of the lads
that came for the night out
um
yeah he said it's my boy's boy's sister
okay cool okay then i find out she's got
a man and a kid at home oh god and they
think she's at her girl's friend's house
oh god no yeah man jesus christ
fair play though
sometimes it's just fair play yeah luck
of the draw from the game is the game
um i tell my boy and he's like
just don't tell the guy the girl's
brother and it'll be okay but when i go
around to my boys that afternoon he's
there
so i just air it out
um he ends up falling out with me and my
boy and then my boy is mad at me because
he thinks i shouldn't have told him am i
a [ __ ] for not wanting to be shady
to my man or should i have just kept my
mouth shut um
i think
putting myself in his shoes i think he
just automatically thought this is going
to come out regardless of what i do so
it comes from i want to be ahead of this
yeah i bet it comes from me then it
comes from the sister because the sister
could have a lapse of judgment or some
she she could catch a conscience and be
like yeah yeah i [ __ ] up the other
night we're out yeah i [ __ ] your boy's
boy blood this happened bro and
obviously he's now gonna go skit skits
bro yeah why did you not know that's my
sister yeah two big man do you know
she's got a husband and a kid why you
[ __ ] her yeah you know so i think he
tried to get ahead of the game ahead of
the curve and
try and not make it into a big thing so
i understand why you told him
but it was one of the it's a
double-edged sword it's a loser lose
regardless
yeah you lose if you don't tell him you
lose if you do
um
i think as well though like he took he
could have taken into consideration
that
his boy's
he's implicated his boy in this yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you brought
your boy into it you had nothing to do
with it and then you suck so say let's
say it's your friend
i've said to you oh i banged your your
brethren's
sister yeah what do you think i should
do and you were like do not tell him bro
do not tell him i think around your
house and he's there in your house
and look in your boat and say
and then i just
sorry
i'm doing it anyway
what were you thinking yeah and then i
tell him and then he falls out with me
and he goes out with you yeah
like
that is a bit of an [ __ ] thing for me
to do that yes
especially in that scenario that i've
implicated you in this
like without you asking to be and then
in your yard i've gone against your
advice and done what i want anyway
and then left you to deal with whatever
comes out of my man's house in your yard
yeah if i wanted to do it i could have
messaged him or i could have talked to
him separately i didn't need to do it in
your boat when you said do not tell him
and i'm like [ __ ] i'm doing it anyway in
your face in your house in your in your
bedroom like i don't care
that's an [ __ ] thing to do that is an
awesome when you put it that way 100
that's an awesome thing to do yeah
because now your boys falling out of you
and you're thinking about i had nothing
to do with this yeah yeah i had nothing
to do with this why you vex at me [ __ ]
yeah that's long but um i get what he's
trying to do like he's trying to get
ahead of the game he probably thinks
bro i need this off my chest and it's
probably gonna come out anyway so let me
just say it now especially when you
stare a man in his boat [ __ ] it
this is too awkward i can see that but
yeah i wouldn't say it's an [ __ ]
thing to tell him the truth
i'm never going to say anyone's an
[ __ ] for telling the truth but
under those circumstances you should
have done it differently 100 should have
done it differently because you [ __ ]
your boy over now yeah and he has a
right to be mad at you i would have been
mad 100
100 i would have met especially if it's
in my house yeah i'd have been like
you're you're a dicker for that yeah
there's literally no reason why you have
to do that get out
get the girl literally get out um but
yeah man that was pretty much open a
shot yeah uh but thank you for sharing
guys um enjoy the rest of your monday
yeah make sure you hon hep hop on over
to patreon to catch thursday's episode
um we've got some more icks coming up on
that one
and yeah we'll see you there love love
[Music]